[Music]
i'm jeff glor co-host of cbs this
morning saturday from antarctica to the
uk we're taking a journey across the
globe to highlight some of the
environmental issues our world is facing
we begin stateside where trillions of
small plastic pellets known as nurdles
have been escaping from petrochemical
plants into waterways and oceans for
decades i spoke with a fourth generation
fisherwoman an environmental activist in
texas who fought one of the largest
plastic manufacturers in the world while
there was a monumental settlement the
problem is not shrinking
picking up a shovel full of pellets and
this is cox's creek
take a trip up cox creek off the gulf of
mexico and it's impossible to miss this
gigantic petrol chemical factory that's
a massive plant what's sometimes harder
to see is what's finding its way out of
it
countless plastic pellets sometimes
called neurals how many pellets are
going into the water on a daily basis
they managed to scoop up
79 billion in two years
diane wilson is a fourth generation
fisherwoman who used to captain a shrimp
boat this is the
polyethylene powder that's all over the
bay she is now an environmental activist
fighting one of the largest plastics
manufacturers in the world this was
never the plan to go from a fisherwoman
to an environmental activist
no
people don't believe it but i am
normally
very quiet i'm an introvert so why this
because it
fell
flat in my lap
the taiwanese conglomerate formosa
plastics first opened this factory in
1983.
it now covers 2500 acres of land near
port lavaca texas
trillions of polyethylene plastic
pellets like these are made here the
first step in making products that we
use every day from plastic bottles to
bags
clothing and electronics
but billions of plastic pellets are also
lost and find their way into waterways
and eventually oceans many washed back
up onto the beach
so this is thousands and thousands of
nerdles
from the most recent high tide line
jace tunnel is the founder of the nerdl
patrol which began tracking pellets
after a massive spill near corpus
christi
it is the weirdest name you've ever
heard but it's a big problem right i
think that's what draws a lot of people
to it is they think nerdl i've never
heard of a nerdle you know what is that
and then you get into talking about well
it's plastic and it shouldn't be in the
environment we know for a fact that
there's a laundry list of over 200
species that are eating these pellets
and then there's also a concern about
what these pellets once they're in the
environment they're absorbing pcbs pahs
ddts you know all those acronyms we hear
about harmful chemicals
these absorb those chemicals
accumulating on our beaches in our
waterways as we speak exactly the hot
spot over here it's estimated as much as
250 000 tons of nerdles enter the ocean
each year we can tell based on the
colors the period of time they've been
out in the sun this has been happening
over many decades in north america the
problem is worst in the gulf this is
really painting as a picture of where
the highest concentrations are all the
way from mexico's yucatan peninsula to
the florida keys
diane wilson began collecting pellets on
the waterways she used to fish
meticulously documenting where and when
they were found
and now her work 30 plastic tubs filled
with evidence has led to a
record-breaking settlement
formosa plastics agreed to pay 50
million dollars to help local fishermen
and environmental cleanup projects in
the area when you first heard that
formosa was going to settle what did you
think
i was just kind of i was in kind of
state of shock about it
one million of that 50 million
settlement will go to fund tunnels nerdl
patrol this isn't just one company that
is the bad actor here it's probably
industry-wide based on the data that
we've accumulated through myrtle patrol
do you think the company or companies
who are responsible for doing this are
committed to fixing it i don't think
that these companies want their pellets
out into the environment i i think that
it is cheaper to leave the product on
the ground after it's spilled than it is
to clean it up they don't want to spend
the money to clean it up right how do
you make them do that regulations
both tunnel and diane wilson say the
formosa settlement is not the end of
their fight
in fact just the opposites every
accessible point in the gulf of mexico
has been sampled
tunnel gets new reports of pellets
washing ashore every day
there are currently 46 companies in
texas alone manufacturing plastics and
tunnels map showing the size of the
problem
is only growing
do you feel like people are getting the
message about this well when i give
presentations one of the key points that
i make is
you know why are we doing all this so i
have a picture of my kids holding up a
bottle of plastic pellets and i tell
people this is for the next generation
you know they shouldn't have to deal
with this they should be picking up
seashells not picking up plastic pellets
off the beach
now we take you to antarctica where
scientists say man-made climate change
is threatening the survival of penguins
our correspondent roxanna saberi
traveled three days by ship from
argentina to elephant island for a
first-hand
look antarctica is one of the most
remote places on the planet but climate
change is hitting it hard we're here
with a group of scientists who want to
know how the warming weather is
affecting this particular species of
penguin the chin strap
elephant island is so far flung
few people have set foot on these rocky
shores
it took us three days of sailing with
environmental activists from greenpeace
crashing through waves and climbing
across rubber rafts to join scientists
counting penguins why count penguins
they come back to the same place to nest
every year which means we can really
keep tabs on their population so by
observing penguins we can get an idea of
the health of this this whole area
alex borowitz observes nesting areas
like this where one parent babysits
while another travels down a penguin
highway to fish for krill
then hikes back up to feed its chick the
shrimp like food
these scientists from stony brook and
northeastern universities count each
chaotic colony on foot with mechanical
clickers
and scan them from above with high-tech
drones
all to see if this population of
chinstrap penguins is dwindling like
elsewhere in the region
the researchers are traveling on
greenpeace ships from island to island
across the antarctic peninsula they're
comparing different penguin populations
to see how they're adapting to climate
change here it may not look like it but
this is one of the fastest warming areas
on earth
one nearby island is actually called
penguin island over the past four
decades its chinstrap population has
plunged by 75 percent
the numbers have dropped across the
region as temperatures have soared by
more than five degrees over 50 years
that's about five times the global
average
so when we see climate change impacting
things down here
glacial melt
warming oceans more acidic oceans
penguins do really interact with with
all of those things
so do krill chinstrap's favorite food
they depend on sea ice to survive sea
ice is really what brings all of the
ocean life here together so with less
sea ice there's less krill
so less food for the chinstrap penguins
that's the idea
after days of counting chin straps on
elephant island 21 22-22 the scientists
invited us onto their ship 32 across
watch them crunch numbers from one
nesting site okay so they've lost
already 50 percent since the early teens
wow
that's amazing
that fits the pattern they're seeing on
the island so far a decline of around
150 000 chin straps since the last major
survey 50 years ago another sign the
researchers say this penguin population
is collapsing across the region it's
very dramatic to have a wildlife
population decline by 50 percent an
unexploited wildlife population they're
not haunted and you think climate change
is the main reason behind it i think
climate change is driving almost all of
the processes down here now in a way
that they've never experienced before
penguins are a lot like people they need
food in a good environment to thrive
these researchers say if the world
continues to warm these birds can show
us how other species even human beings
will be affected by climate change
last year we traveled to the yucatan
peninsula in mexico where scientists are
trying to figure out why massive waves
of seaweed are washing up on beaches
researchers say it's proving to be an
ecological and economical problem with
no end in sight
it is the biggest algae bloom in the
world
massive waves of seaweed called
sargassum washing up on shore
day after day
this beach was just clean today yes
a couple of hours and the seaweed will
be on the beach again
jose escalante has owned a small hotel
in tulum mexico for eight years
every day workers here and up and down
the yucatan peninsula remove tons and
tons of decomposing sargassum from
beaches
every night it comes back
rosa rodriguez martinez from mexico's
national university is trying to figure
out why
we are getting sargassum almost from
march to october
so basically more than half of the year
we receive maximum amounts whereas
before it was how long before maybe two
or three weeks during the summer that's
a huge difference
yes it's impressive impressive is one
word for it a problem big problem is
another it's a problem economical
problem ecological and probably human
health problem also
since 2011 the amount of sargassum in
the atlantic has increased dramatically
it currently forms a 5 000 mile mass
from africa to the caribbean it is
estimated to weigh 22 million tons
why is it so bad right now
i think it's because we have polluted
the sea too much so now we have a lot of
nutrients and the algae are taking
advantage of it
fertilizer runoff from brazil increased
by deforestation is believed to be the
largest fuel source for the sargassum
that combined with warming ocean water
and changing ocean currents has put the
yucatan squarely in the crosshairs
it has gotten so bad the mexican navy
has just been put in charge of dealing
with this problem
they took us up on a reconnaissance
mission to locate the largest sargassum
waves
we are fully aware that we're only
addressing the effects of sargassum rear
admiral enrique flores morado told us
the navy will build new sargassum
busting ships to reel in as much as they
can
but that does not solve any problem
in reality the causes have to be
addressed but given the lack of research
we're now implementing immediate actions
right now many towns and resort owners
are using floating barriers to corral
and collect sargassum including in
puerto morelos half an hour south of
cancun
we can say for sure that we are the
first destination in the whole
mexican caribbean with already a control
above this organization there's a lot of
it though yeah yeah because this area we
are
it doesn't look controlled no no hector
tamayo is in charge of tourism here
how many trucks go in and out each day
more than
50. more than 50 trucks
just of sargassum every day
carted in and out of here and then we
just start mixing that with the sargasso
some are developing novel ways to use
sargassum including omar vasquez who's
building homes with it they're better
than the other brakes
the sargassum is mixed with clay and
compost by foot and then compressed into
bricks
i mean it's ironic because i grew up
without a house
without a home
we crossed the border to the states when
i was eight years old and then came back
i came back to live my mexican dream
your mexican dream yes it does have not
even a gram of cement everything is
organic even though vasquez says his
homes are 100 organic there may be an
issue with what accumulates in the
sargassum at sea
rosa rodriguez's latest research shows
sargassum is high in heavy metals like
lead and arsenic
and disposal is a major issue this is
one of the places we found where the
sargassum is taken it's a dump site
miles into the jungle far away from the
ocean
it's unclear if the sargassum left here
seeps into the ground goes up into the
air
or just sits here forever
sargassum is either being dumped inland
or buried under the beach which is
illegal
it is a crisis stretching across the
caribbean with no end in sight
for folks watching this who may not be
familiar with this problem or what's
happening here
what do you say
it's something that is happening to the
world not not just to the region this is
just a consequence of the entire planet
being
you know
in trouble
researchers say an estimated 150 million
people live on land that will be below
the high tide line 30 years from now
brook silva braga takes us to norfolk
virginia where citizens are coming
together with a unique effort to protect
their community from rising seas
the water comes up from cali bay
into the street you see it just flowing
right now it's flowing right into your
yard
and as the tide rose the water kept
creeping toward john blumming's house
which now sits on stilts after i bought
the house i realized it was a common
occurrence
after you bought that after i bought the
house uh how much of a financial
surprise was that uh about uh 90 000 to
lift it up
low-lying norfolk has always faced
flooding from hurricanes
like isabel back in 2003 but what we saw
in john's front yard is something
different when the tide comes up we get
a little flooding seawater brought to
land by nothing more than a high tide it
could be a sunny day like today sharon
bean lives by the water here too she
told us the house can still get flood
insurance they just had to cut power to
the outlets on the ground floor i think
it's worse in the fall
then she showed us videos of kayakers
paddling down her street and her dog han
solo floating in space above the same
wall where we were sitting and in a year
that happens how many times oh i would
say
maybe 26
26 times yes it's up here all the time
it's a lot
the u.s government says globally the sea
level has risen more than three inches
in just the last 25 years
and because of things like erosion and
ocean currents some places have faced
more rise than others norfolk has
evidence of that thanks to a title gauge
dating back to 1927.
since sewell's point gauge in the city
of norfolk was installed there near the
naval base it's raised by nearly a foot
and a half derrick loftus a researcher
from the virginia institute of marine
science says that foot and a half of
change comes not just from the water
rising but also because over development
of norfolk's marshy soil has been
sinking the land we think this will get
worse so we don't really know by the
year 2050 i mean we're kind of expecting
an increase of somewhere between 0.7 to
1 foot of water another foot higher yeah
you say that so calmly yeah we've been
researching it for years so i feel like
i've known this for a while but but
resignation in norfolk may be as common
as water in the streets
you can see it's a continuation of the
sidewalk at least that's how it felt to
dave mayfield three years ago as he
wrapped up a career as an environmental
journalist for the local paper i was
feeling a bit depressed we're seeing
flooding
more and more
people are being inconvenienced and yet
nothing happens yeah nothing happens i
wanted to do something that
might make a difference you know at
least in helping engage people so
mayfield got an idea he knew each fall
the alignment of the moon earth and sun
caused what's known as a king tide in
otherwise normal high tide that's
especially strong and more importantly
predictable we would get as many people
as possible out on one day to measure an
unusually high tide have their data
crowdsourced into a model improving
flood forecasting he partnered with a
group that had developed a tide mapping
app and dubbed the event catch the king
to his surprise more than 700 people
turned out we've got high tide in about
30 minutes guinness certified it as the
world's largest ever environmental
survey i think what i underestimated was
the innate desire of people to be part
of something larger that might result in
something good
there have now been three annual catch
the king events and the idea has
inundated other parts of the calendar if
the tie charts call for flooding in
coastal virginia you'll probably find a
mapper at the high water mark so what we
do is we walk
along the water line at high tide
and about every five feet
we press a button and that records our
exact location on the gps and here's
what i've done today that's the outline
of the water yes every place that i have
stopped and and
pushed the app
mappers like bill weary have now pushed
the app tens of thousands of times yeah
i'm going to take a look at the data
that's coming in there their readings
end up in the hands of researchers like
derek loftis it tells us whether our
model is right or wrong which scientists
live and die by also what's particularly
useful is it helps us find areas for
potential improvement for example most
the flooding you'll see today is due to
storm drainage systems and as mayfield
hoped more than anything it's given
ordinary people a way to do something
about a problem no one person can do
much about
although we can't stop the tides
eventually some sort of uh preventative
action
is going to be well it is needed and the
more and more data that scientists have
i think the better we'll be able to
prevent the tide
from causing harm to the neighborhood
may it all come out of what we're doing
the unusually high tide that we might
see on our
annual project day for catch the king
is going to be a routine high tide not
many decades from now so we provide i
think a window into the future
more than 25 years ago the northwest
forest plan was put in place to protect
more than 24 million acres of forest in
the pacific northwest but the debate
over who's in charge of america's
ancient forests is under scrutiny
november two one two two sierra runway
two clear takeoff our trip began in a
small plane maybe the best way to see
what's happening in western oregon you
can see where there's a few trees left
here and there that's required by oregon
law our guide chandra laguie of the
group oregon wild we're actually really
in the heart of some serious logging
right now
the views from overhead can be jarring
mountains teeming with towering trees
followed by winding cutouts of nothing
but stumps
this is what modern day clear cutting
looks like
giant machines handle massive trees like
matchsticks
this land has never been lost no it
hasn't
this is a place where none of that has
happened a so-called old growth forest
we only have about 15 percent of the
forest that once screwed trees like this
that are left
areas like this were protected by the
northwest forest plan which was signed
in 1994 and impacted more than 24
million acres of federal land in oregon
california and washington was the
northwest forest plan a success or
failure from an environmental
perspective it's a success but
we're only 25 years in it's kind of a
long term experiment
logging on federal lands has dropped by
as much as 90 percent
but on state-owned and private land
time lapse of satellite images over
northwest oregon give a sense of just
how common clear cutting still is
lague says it has a lasting impact
forests capture carbon helping to cool
the earth and slow climate change
logging companies are required by law to
replant new trees after clear cuts
but it can take a decade or more before
a young forest absorbs as much carbon as
an old one not every company like yours
is willing to talk about their story or
take us to places like this why why do
you do that i think we as an industry
have not done a very good job
historically of telling our story todd
payne is the ceo of seneca jones a
timber giant in western oregon has the
northwest forest plan been a success or
failure in your estimation honestly
speaking i think it was a failure payne
believes the northwest forest plan is
choking growth and the hands-off
approach environmentalists advocate is
leading to more wildfires because
forests have been neglected
he took us to one of seneca's expansive
tree farms an hour and a half outside
eugene where they operate on 50-year
cycles this area next to us was
clear-cut about 55 years ago for the
first time and then clear-cut again
three or four years ago three years ago
correct why clear-cut we're mimicking
what mother nature's done for for
billions of years but this looks
traumatic for a lot of people when they
see something like this um i actually
look at it quite different i think it's
it's somewhat aesthetically pleasing you
think that looks aesthetically pleasing
i do maybe it's uh somewhat biased but
i look at this and and i i see
sustainability rejuvenation timber
companies have also traditionally used a
practice called aerial spraying
chemicals dropped via helicopter to kill
any vegetation other than trees used for
lumber a lot of people are concerned
about the spring well i think people are
just
not informed well on that subject we use
it once or twice in a 50-year cycle it
ultimately flows somewhere though no it
doesn't
a lot of times this stuff doesn't flow
off the landscape the product will
adhere to the vegetation that it's
targeted for and stay there nancy
webster who lives up the coast in
rockaway beach oregon is worried those
chemicals seep into her drinking water
the fight between environmentalists and
logging companies is not new but this
seems like the newest chapter
right this affects the fish the wildlife
and we are up against large corporations
and to even counter it you know you need
science and legal help and it's it's
really difficult for small communities
today the situation may be reaching a
critical point because the federal
government wants to suspend a public
review process which logging companies
say needlessly ties them up in court
should there be a public review process
when logging takes place on public lands
well we have professionals in place in
in our federal agencies that are
managing these lands and i think we need
to let them do that work in other words
he wants groups like oregon wild to stay
away the argument is from them that if
they're not able to log
people can't build homes yeah well no
one's talking about shutting down
logging we're talking about what i feel
are common sense changes that do less
damage to the environment that we all
share
ligue wants to see forests thin not
clear-cut a far less invasive approach
though she acknowledges it is more
expensive and would produce less lumber
i think people do need to come to grips
with the fact that the wood that they
use to build houses or anything else
comes from clear-cutting
forests in places like oregon so what
you're saying is there's a price to pay
for a better world
i think in order to make amends
in some way that there is a price to pay
for that
and i think it's worth it
you can find news and more stories like
this on cbs this morning from 7 to 9 a.m
and you can find news 24 7 right here on
cbsn featuring live anchored coverage
available for free across all platforms
thanks for joining us
take care of each other